well right now u.s senators are grilling
senior defense officials about the
withdrawal of military forces from
afghanistan and the collapse of the
afghan government defense secretary
lloyd austin joint chiefs of staff
chairman mark milley and the head of
central command general kenneth mckenzie
are all testifying the biden
administration has been widely accused
of being unprepared for the fall of
kabul senior officials have admitted
that taliban forces advanced far more
quickly than anticipated
we helped build the state mr chairman
but we could not forge a nation
the fact that the afghan army that we
and our partners trained simply melted
away
in many cases without firing a shot took
us all by surprise and it would be
dishonest to claim otherwise
we need to consider some uncomfortable
truths
that we didn't fully comprehend the
depth of corruption and poor leadership
in the senior ranks
that we didn't grasp the damaging effect
affect the frequent and unexplained
rotations by president ghani of his
commanders
that we didn't anticipate the snowball
effect effect caused by the deals that
the taliban commanders struck with local
leaders in a wake of the doha agreement
and that the doha agreement itself had a
demoralizing effect on afghan soldiers
while those proceedings are continuing
right now on capitol hill let's listen
but to the families of those who have
been deployed over and over again into
iraq and afghanistan over the course of
the last 20 years
they are relieved that america is now
turning the page and rejecting the
notion that we should be a nation in
permanent war
second the effort to evacuate more than
120 000 people to safety under chaotic
circumstances was remarkable i visited
the dulles expo center the principal
arrival point for about 80 percent of
the afghans i also visited fort lee the
first of the eight forts that process
afghans and i visited with afghans our
troops the many federal agencies working
together ngos
the competent and compassionate service
on the american side and the deep
gratitude among afghans made a deep
impression on me we should do all we can
to make that transition to safe life in
america as productive as possible
my chief criticism and question is this
why did the afghan security force and
civilian government collapse so quickly
and why did the u.s so overestimate
their capacity
the second half of the question why we
overestimated their capacity is very
important to any who have said we
couldn't see this coming the members of
this committee know that's wrong
an immediate collapse may not have been
the most likely outcome but we have
heard for years particularly from the
intel community that dod estimates of
afghan strength were way too optimistic
i believe the u.s government had a good
evacuation plan but it was premised on
an afghan civilian and military
government that showed high resistance
to the taliban and so we did not
adequately plan for the real possibility
of a quick collapse we need to explore
both military and interagency
decision-making processes to understand
why we were unrealistic and how to
correct that going forward
but the most important part of the
question is why a military we had
trained for 20 years at a cost of 800
plus billion dollars collapsed so
quickly i can think of three reasons but
after i put them on the table i would
like each of you beginning with general
mckenzie to address the question and if
we can't we can do it when we come back
after lunch
first the lightning collapse may show
that our training was insufficient and
that it did not
prepare the afghan military to defend
the country on their own that should
have been our goal but we failed to
accomplish it if so how must we change
our thinking about training foreign
militaries
second the lightning collapse may not
prove that the nsf were poor fighters
but that they were demoralized did they
lack confidence in their own political
and military leaders were they
demoralized by a 2020 peace agreement
between the u.s and the taliban that
didn't even include the afghan
government mr chair i'd like to
introduce the peace agreement for the
record
objection did u.s and allied funding
deepen a culture of corruption that long
predated our involvement even the best
fighting force may give in if they have
no confidence in their leadership
third the lightning collapse may show
that we wanted things for afghans that
afghan leadership did not want for
themselves we celebrated gains in public
health and women's education and we
assumed that afghans would fight to
preserve those gains rather than allow
the taliban to take over in other words
we thought we knew what afghans wanted
what they feared and what they would
fight for
but was our belief though
well-intentioned incredibly naive we
can't get one third of americans to take
a coveted vaccine or accept the results
of a presidential election do we really
think we can transform the culture of
another nation
so to each of our witnesses when we
return in the second round i will ask
you this question why do you believe the
afghan military and civilian government
collapsed so quickly without all your
future well let's bring in our
correspondent patty culhane she's
watching proceedings for us in
washington dc patty some very tough
questions there to answer today
including some as we've been hearing
pointed ones about intelligence failures
and i imagine also about civilian
casualties
they did bring up that drone strike
which when it first happened general
mark milley said was a right to strike
it turned out that it was an aid worker
and ten afghans died including seven
children uh the on intelligence i
thought this was somewhat newsworthy uh
general milley said that the
intelligence was a complete failure and
he pointed to perhaps why he said look
we can point to how many guns and how
many planes and how many helicopters and
humvees we've given them but we don't
know what the hearts of the soldiers are
unless we have advisors on the ground
with them and he said we stopped putting
advisors with them for three years so
another thing he said is one of the
lessons they're learning is perhaps they
try to make the afghan military too much
like the american military trying to
give them high-tech equipment when
perhaps that's not what was needed
as for exactly
how the pentagon though didn't see this
coming the pentagon likes to say they
have a plan for everything we just heard
the secretary of defense admit that they
never tabletop exercises to how they
plan
tabletop exercises that they never had
one where it showed the complete
collapse of the taliban so lots of
pointed questions being asked but the
big one they want to know is how many
americans are still in afghanistan
they're trying to point the finger at
state we just heard from a u.s senator
said no i'm going to need those numbers
by the end of this hearing so a lot of
pointed questions so far a lot of blame
game going on we see people saying that
donald trump made the deal with the
taliban and so it was doomed mission
from that point on and then republicans
are saying look what joe biden was
responsible for the drawdown that was
just so chaotic and some say
embarrassing
pasha calhan there watching those
proceedings for us on capitol hill
thanks so much patty
well meanwhile in afghanistan the
taliban says it's planning to implement
a constitution from nearly six decades
ago now afghanistan's new rulers want to
apply it only where it doesn't conflict
with their version of islamic law the
existing constitution was drawn up with
the help of the u.s back in 2004 but the
taliban says it wants no foreign
interference hashem mahalbara has more
now from kabul
the taliban seem to be trying to
extend an olive branch to the
international community by saying look
we could have resurrected the
constitutional declaration of 1998 when
the taliban were in power here in
afghanistan instead we chose to go for
the 1964 constitution why that
constitution in particular because it's
widely seen as the constitution that
paved the way for constitutional
democracy protected the right of
expression the right the freedom of
expression and the freedom of thought he
established independent institutions
with an independent judiciary
however there's a caveat to that
constitution 1964
states that the king has the right to
dissolve the parliament and appoint the
prime minister under the current
situation it seems that
the
supreme leader of the taliban the emir
al-mu'min the commander of the faithful
will ultimately have the final say he
could be the one to fire the government
and point in your parliament
dissolve the parliament sorry or decide
that this provision is in conflict with
the sharia law and therefore it has to
be
it has to be changed
well let's now speak to jennifer
mutavashvili she's a non-resident senior
fellow at the atlantic council's eurasia
center focusing on central asia and
afghanistan she joins us now from
pittsburgh jennifer this is a
constitution that grants women the right
to vote but given that the taliban says
they'll eliminate any elements that they
disagree with what do you think it's
actually going to look like
don't think that they are implementing
this constitution to give women the
rights to vote and they've been very
clear that they don't think that
democracy is the way forward uh they're
implementing this constitution to get
political recognition simply uh to
establish a political order but without
a constitution it would be very hard for
them to have a government so this
constitution becomes very important for
them instrumentally to get that kind of
international recognition and that
they've said that they'll be able to
cherry-pick the parts of the
constitution that they believe
contradict
contradict their rule and they've been
pretty clear about democracy as not
being um symbolic of where they think
the country needs to go well there have
been a lot of promises that taliban
ruled this time round would take a more
inclusive form but there are obviously
still no women in the caretaker
government does this move as you suggest
get them more of the legitimacy that
they crave in the eyes of the world or
does that potentially backfire
i think it gives them a framework a
framework for governance it creates you
know as the correspondent just said as
the story from kabul said it gives the
head of the taliban the right sort of
the power of a king and he can then
allow the government to create laws and
dismiss laws as he sees fit so it really
gives authoritarian power this you know
did create a constitutional monarchy it
wasn't a democracy so um you know i
don't think it it it does much in terms
of changing much on the ground uh but it
does give a framework for laws and i
think this is just an incremental step
that they're trying to to use to get
this recognition
sure if they are cherry-picking parts of
the constitution then who right now
decides what to keep and what to get rid
of
it's the senior leadership and they're
using this as a bargaining chip with the
international community so they're using
gender rights they're using uh
inclusivity is something that they can
bargain with with the international
community in order to get aid this is a
very dangerous game that they're playing
uh because on the one hand they're
they're selecting this constitution not
the 2004 constitution they're going back
to this constitution because they say
that the 2004 constitution was created
by the puppets the puppet government it
was created by the international by the
united states and foreigners so the 1964
constitution in their eyes is more pure
the danger with using women's rights and
inclusivity is bargaining chips to get
international aid is the taliban are
then going to fall prey to the same trap
that they accuse the ghani government of
they're positioning themselves before
international donors and changing their
position based on what aid that they can
receive this creates a huge opening for
groups like isis and others who will
then accuse the taliban of becoming
puppets to the foreigners because
they're using this to get leverage for
aid well jennifer there is a commission
that was meant to be formed next year i
believe to draft a new constitution how
does that all fit into this process
could we potentially see that entire
constitutional process abandoned after
this happens
no this is actually an old play in fact
the united states adopted this 1964
constitution in 2001 right after the
taliban government collapsed the
previous taliban government and so for
three years the 1964 constitution was
used as the constitutional framework in
afghanistan before the 2004 constitution
was established and what that does is it
allows the framework of government to
continue it allows the center to
continue appoint ministers continue to
point to provincial governors and
district governors the same way that the
1964 constitution did in fact the 2004
constitution was hardly a departure from
this 1964 constitution there were many
things uh that these two constitutions
had uh
they were quite similar to one another
and that they were both very
authoritarian in nature so this is not a
good sign uh going into the next few
months
very interesting indeed jennifer mutava
villi there a non-resident senior fellow
at the atlantic council's eurasia center
thanks so much for sharing your
expertise with us on al jazeera thanks
for joining us jennifer
thank you